if you were a kid back in the 90s and
early 2000s
then chances are you were probably
watching the animated series about the
batman
behind every great animated hero is a
great voice actor
and for me that actor is kevin conroy
how was that that was good kevin keep
going okay
i am vengeance i am the knight
i am batman
is that okay
i'm kevin conroy uh i've been playing
the voice
of batman since 1991
for 29 years jokers opened every cell in
arkham
it started with batman the animated
series
and then the adventures of batman and
robin and then came the justice league
batman beyond and in the interim there
was
mask of the phantasm sub-zero killing
joke
i would like to claim that i have been
the only voice of batman for any
animated show
but i've been doing it the longest of
anybody and i've been the one that's
sort of referred to as the animated
voice come into the light
i was a new york theater actor i studied
at juilliard
and the people i worked with were robin
williams
kelsey grammer harriet harris francis
conroy
i did broadway off-broadway a lot of
classics shakespeare the greeks
address your love and might to honor
helen
and so when my agent told me they were
doing this new animated batman
show the only thing i knew about batman
was the
adam west show i didn't even know it had
never been an animated show i was that
naive to it
and so when i was first auditioning for
the role the director described it as
this very dark
noir character i went to exactly what i
know
which is the theater and so i used my
imagination to fill that out
and for me with my voice try to create
a dark gritty filthy
new york street so once i had
came up with this voice in the recording
studio everything got really still
in there and i thought oh i just screwed
up i have so
blown this and then the casting director
came running inside she said you nailed
it you you nailed it
[Music]
joker where did he go my favorite
episodes
of any of the shows are the ones that
deal with the
complexity of the man of bruce wayne
perchance to dream is a wonderful
episode where he's drugged
and he goes back into his childhood and
he deals with his father
so i was the voice of batman and bruce
wayne and then i was drugged batman
and then i was adolescent to bruce wayne
and i was thomas wayne my father
so in the one episode i did five voices
so any episode that dealt with
that psychology that makes up batman
i love you know what's going on this is
a dream
tell me where it is voicing batman
for 29 years has been an extraordinary
experience
because it evolved from being a
an acting job to being kind of the
embodiment
of a cultural touchdown for a lot of
people
people come up to me all the time and
just want to grab me and hug me
because they know me i've shared my
deepest emotional life with them
through my performance and through my
voice so the advice i would give to the
next person who comes along to voice
batman
um is don't because i'm still here no
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
joker where did he go
joker where did he go